everybody
chaos confusion and panic the injured
and dead are everywhere
money and food is being distributed to
the poor a tradition during Ramadan
the Stampede broke out as this side in
Karachi was overwhelmed by crowds of
desperate people
those behind us didn't stop they kept
pushing I was crushed too the last thing
I remember is that my sister fell on me
I tried to find my sister but I couldn't
when the crowd cleared I saw both of
them my sisters lying dead
women and children were killed as the
crowd got out of control
there have been other stampedes at food
distribution centers this week but this
was the deadliest
money was being distributed among the
poor today a large crowd had gathered
which resulted in a stampede efforts to
control the crowd made things worse some
people drowned a nearby stream others
were trampled on their foot
is it a 50-year high and families are
struggling to survive
the cost of basic Goods like flower have
soared nearly 50 percent this past year
families of the Dead say they're tired
of political infighting and are
demanding Solutions
women have been full
the Prime Minister keeps blaming former
leader Imran Khan for everything Khan is
not responsible he is responsible there
is no gas no electricity no water
everything is so expensive they should
die of Shame
police have sealed off the area they've
already arrested several people the
organizers are being blamed for failing
to inform local authorities about the
event
but so long as Pakistani families remain
in dire conditions more tragedies like
this one could be difficult to avoid
Vinton Monahan Al Jazeera